We come to pitching and the lateral axis.
The lateral axis — this axis through the wing. We have the lateral axis, we have the longitudinal axis, we have the vertical axis.
Movement around the lateral axis — that's called pitching.
It's important so that, when we for example fly into a thermal,
that's a very good pilot who has mastered this.
When pitching, always make sure that we're not too early with the brake and not too fast.
I'll demonstrate it shortly.
But the most common errors are simply trying to pull too fast and too deep,
to build up the pitching strongly.
It's more about the timing of the brake than about the intensity.
With bigger pendulum swings we have to pull more brake — that's logical.
Sure, we can't avoid that.
But in the beginning what's decisive is that we brake slowly and when we go with the brakes another time.
Pitching also means that we try with the body to seek a bit of contact with the harness.
So push the knees a bit apart.
Look at the wing, look at the flight direction.
So we don't start only with the wing.
We don't start just staring at the wing, but also with a bit of a look forward,
so we see, all right, the direction is going.
Or where is the wing actually going?
Good. When pitching I recommend not wrapping the brakes.
Instead, keep the brakes at the bridle in the hand.
Because we can also fully release the brakes to let the wing go.
Which is often not the case with the brake wrapped.
Okay, good.
Then I'll say on the radio, pull, pull, pull.
And with each pull, it'll be about 3–4 centimetres.
That means pull the first 15–20 centimetres pretty slowly.
I'll say on the radio: pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull.
Hands up.
Did you see that?
So really start slowly, but hands up as fast as you can.
Pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull.
Hands up, snap, right?
That's a real brisk hands-up.
Try maybe even a bit on the riser,
to work in long position with the brakes,
so you don't go out to the sides with the brakes.
Really a nice guidance, beautifully slow,
then wait, completely.
Wait and so.
And here's the thing: through the braking,
you swing forward.
Now we wait until the wing is back at the dead point
and then we let the brakes go,
meaning the wing accelerates full gas.
And now we have to wait until we've swung through
underneath the wing again.
If we brake the wing during the downward motion,
we take away all the energy
we just built up.
And that's why it's so important that we wait
until we carry all the energy, all the speed
and have swung through underneath the wing.
That means, just like on a swing, we're already
in the slight downward motion again.
And right then comes another brake input.
Now on the second or also third time.
Just a bit deeper.
That means brake.
Pull, pull, pull, pull, pull.
The motivation up, snap, right?
That one was quietly a bit deeper, fine, no problem.
At handy speed.
Then if it's not quite happy, I'll say to you,
okay, now brake again one more time.
So do it once more.
That means you swing through underneath.
When you're a bit in the climb phase,
then again pull, pull, pull, pull, pull.
Hands up.
And now it's now that we have the wing come forward.
Let's say 45 to 60 degrees.
And then we want to stop it there in front.
Stop it right in front.
That means stop it here in front.
When I say, pull, pull, pull, pull.
Brake input.
I say, hands up.
When I'm symmetric and brisk, the hands up.
And then I'll say on the radio, wait.
Then you really have to wait until you've swung past the wing.
And through the dead point, upward and on the way.
And then the command comes from me only after that.
Brake, pull, pull, pull, pull, hands up.
When braking, always make sure
that we start symmetrically.
If right is a bit deeper than left,
then we make a small right turn.
Or if when releasing,
you bring the right hand up a bit earlier than the left, or the other way around.
Then there too we make a turn to one side.
And that wouldn't be the goal.
Now, that's a source of error,
where it can happen while pitching.
That's why I ask you to simply go a bit slower at the beginning.
I'll say pull a bit more or a bit deeper.
If you pull too fast and too deep at the beginning,
then you'll stall the wing.
Important is — how do you see that from below?
When I say, hands up.
Really leave the hands up.
Let the wing fly forward.
If we've pulled the wing too far into the stall, so to speak.
So it really has tilted a bit backwards,
then it can be that the wing accelerates forward
and collapses at the front.
And we let that happen.
We just leave the hands up.
We possibly only react to the collapse.
That means, if the wing stays caught in on one side,
then we take direction out of it.
So stabilise direction.
But that comes from me — pull left brake
or right brake, depending on what the case is.
As a rule the wing recovers on its own and without
us having to do anything.
That's a bit important.
As soon as we've stalled the wing once,
leave the hands up, leave them up and wait,
until the wing has recovered from all of it.
If we somehow have a collapse-cravat,
whatever, then we only react to that.